hey everybody is Jessie and today we're
gonna have a shorter than normal stream
so I have a performance review at 2:30
Eastern Time
so that means like 59 minutes from now
so today I'm gonna just do some easy
things that we can finish within that
time frame so it's mostly going to be
like some CSS so I'll show you very
quickly what I've done I've only been I
today has been very busy in terms of
having to do things out of the office so
I haven't really had that much time to
work on this project but I did get this
drop down in here so the Select so this
is using the material UI select and you
can see it is working so still not
perfect so it's going down on two lines
so I need to adjust some things you know
with the media queries and maybe you get
rid of some this pad anything so not not
too bad so I guess I guess we can start
by cleaning some of this up I think we
can definitely get this finished and
then maybe move on and just do you know
some of the little UI things that we've
been talking about and saying like hey
like we're definitely gonna want to do
this at some point well today's a good
day to do that so hate everybody that's
joining in the stream on Instagram so I
am doing live coding so you can't see my
screen on Instagram if you'd like to see
the code check out the free code camp
YouTube channel and there's a live
stream going on there as well and you'll
be able to see my screen
and all the code so let me bring over
let's see
bring over my terminal so now I need
that at some point and say hey to
everybody in the live chat awesome gold
s do you have any tips because I'm just
starting out if you want to do web dev
my good tip is start with free code camp
and I get through as much as you can at
least in the front-end portion of it and
that'll be a really good starting point
and don't be afraid to ask questions in
in the chat there's a lot of
knowledgeable people and will will help
you out as much as we can all right so
let's let's get started all right it's a
really easy thing that we can accomplish
and for sure get something done is I'd
like this to be centered yeah I
definitely think to be centered because
especially since we'll be on mobile I
think it would look nicer yeah it would
look nicer centered it might not look
bad if it was a little bit wider as well
but I don't really want it to be full
with you know on the screen size like
this so for now we'll just Center it so
I'm gonna inspect this and I'll bring
over dev tools so if you're if you're
really just kind of starting out and you
haven't used dev tools very often you
should get get acquainted with dev tools
because it's going to be like your best
friend in terms of helping you figure
out how sites are built and try to
change things without having to actually
do anything with the code or save it you
can just go to change things any any
site that
that you're on you can use dev tools on
and just switch things around and see
how you like it so for now what I'm
trying to do is find out where our
container div is for this and we'll see
how we can do this so maybe first thing
I'm gonna try is text-align:center okay
that somewhat accomplished what I wanted
so it has moved these into the center
and I did not want that so if I add left
there we go so I can add text-align:left
let's make sure that that looks all
right
okay not bad
okay and I guess the width of that is
it's alright in terms of the words in
here it's definitely sufficient to fit
even our longest item all right so it
looks like that's what we're gonna have
to do we're gonna on this div will do
text-align:center that'll bring it to
the center and then we'll make sure on
the container div for our select input
we do text-align:left so now it's just a
matter of making sure that we can get
the style on this container div so
you'll see what I mean in a second so we
have we're using react and then react we
we don't use in normal HTML it looks
somewhat like HTML but it's actually JSX
which is a JavaScript basically it seems
and it works like a JavaScript HTML mix
okay so you can do a lot of normal HTML
things but then you can also do some
JavaScript things like some of the stuff
we're doing here so this is actually a
react component our select field so you
see you don't see a bunch of divs and
then an input we just see this component
so this reference is some other
JavaScript file that actually does have
all the markup that we just saw in dev
tools so what I'm going to try to do and
this should work is we're gonna put a
class name actually I can double check
let's double check since we have it
right here because I think I have it up
here yep I already have the Select field
documentation so we're using material UI
for a lot of our components so in the
documentation we should see style
readiness a salute element
okay we should be able to put the style
I didn't see a class so I'm actually
assuming both ways I was thinking of
doing this will work so initially I was
gonna put a class name here so that we
can keep all of our styles in this one
file this logos dot s CSS file but in
this in this case I think I'd like to do
it like this style text-align:left
okay is that next align left' okay so
when we're in react if we want to put a
style on an element we can put it in
double curly curly brackets it's not if
you break down the syntax it makes sense
right because we need the curly brackets
first to say hey we're gonna do some
JavaScript and then once we're inside
here we want to make an object right so
we use our curly brackets and then this
is just a key value pair within that
object and that's our CSS of course the
camel casing makes sense right because
if we would have left the - and it would
have been interpreted as a minus sign
alright so this is our style here and
let's let's go with the style one here
as well because it'll save it the extra
step of putting the class on and then
doing something with it over here so we
want to do text aligned just like we did
below and this time we're gonna do
Center and let's see how that works out
so we've saved that we have
an automatic refresh so we should see it
yep and that's exactly what we expected
great okay so you can see with dev tools
that allowed us to preview our change
first and then when we liked what it
looked like then we took it and put it
in the code may not seem like a big deal
with what we just did but it can save
you a lot of time depending on on what
you're working on okay
and if if you're not sure why I'm not
getting real images here it's just I
have what I'm working on localhost I
can't pull the images so it's I was
trying to get it to actually work I
think Patrick who's in the live chat
often had given some advice as to how to
get that to work and I just ran out of
time so these would be logos normally
they're supposed to be logos alright
that looks pretty good now for this the
first thing I'm gonna do is get rid of a
lot of the space between these and I I
don't think that that'll give us
completely what we want we may have to
adjust it I don't want to take this
space too far in right because I want I
want them to be distinct and I also
don't really want to decrease the font
size at all
so we'll see we'll see what we can do I
actually might be able to just remove
this this year of Mercy because that was
like two years ago so I doubt we need
that logo anymore and since this is our
longest one if I reduce the size and
remove this I think it should be okay
yeah now if we add another category
later on I'll have to I'll have to work
on that but these categories have been
set and have not changed at all for
nearly
a year and a half so it's it's not
something that's likely to change
frequently okay so let's let's do that
let's take out the year of mercy one and
we'll see where that that gives us just
in case I wasn't clear about it I don't
want these to go on to two lines I want
it all to stay one line so that's why I
need to reduce the width of that section
all right so let's remove that and this
will give me a chance to show you how
we're populating that in case you you
didn't get to see it I think maybe two
days ago we set this up so all of the
tab names are here and we go when we go
to create the tabs we get the tabs here
and then we go over all right so we
iterate over that and then produce these
allies that have that name and then we
also use as a key we use the the value
right which we're calling tab key here
and that produces all those those tabs
and we're doing a similar thing to
produce the each item in that select so
if we want to change it all we have to
do is remove it here and it'll remove it
in both menus which is kind of nice
saves a little bit of time so let's
remove that and we should see this going
away yep okay so that's gone I don't
think that'll solve the problem
completely we'll give it a shot no it
doesn't all right let's reduce some of
the space in here so if you remember
when we first did this earlier in the
week we had set it up so that we had
padding
around the the a tags themselves so it
gave us a bigger click target and then
on the tabs the the allies we added the
margins so that there was a gap in
between the clickable area so if you see
as I scroll through you can see that
cursor change so that there's still that
little gap and I I wanted to have that
gap to help prevent people from
accidentally clicking on their own
category but if we need to take it down
to where there's no gap anymore that's
acceptable I'm ok with that hopefully we
won't have to take it down that far so I
still want to leave a nice size click
area so I'm not going to reduce that at
all if I can help it but I would like to
reduce the margin so here's where we set
that margin right now we have 8 pixels
on each side so that means there's 16
pixels right of area that's just spacing
not clickable area so let's drop that
down by half so if we go 4 pixels here
then that really gives us 8 pixels in
between and it still looks it definitely
looks distinct alright because remember
we also have 8 pixels of padding as well
oops
no still not enough not quite enough so
let's reduce that even more I'm gonna go
down to two I'm kind of afraid I might
have to go even further oh yes
that works all right great so it works
he just barely works but we've dropped
that down so that we still have space
it's still these are still distinct I
mean no one's gonna mistake this for a
sentence right these are definitely you
know spaced out I would say at least
three or four times the normal width of
a space in a sentence okay all right
that works and also the the users are
used to a setup that is similar to this
with spacing that is similar actually
there there may be even less spacing in
the current site so from a user's
perspective they they're already used to
having a setup like this and clicking it
so I think we'll be fine like this so
now that we've done this and we've
reduced that margin we can just copy and
paste it for in this case I mean it's
not that hard to remember it too but
it's nice to be able to copy and paste
straight from dev tools into our code so
we have our sass file sass is a what's
called a CSS preprocessor it lets you do
some nice things that you can't really
do the CSS like set variables and there
are a lot of other things you can do as
well
and then it you can have your sass file
get turned into CSS so that a browser
can understand it so we just need to
find that tab so here was our tab and
there's where we had it our 8 pixels
initially and we'll paste in our two
pixels save it
and I don't think I'm better hard
refresh because I want to remove what we
did in here there we go and that works
right so I sometimes I'll forget and if
I don't do a hard refresh like let's say
it's just that you can have like hot
module reloading and so it doesn't
exactly cause a page refresh so
occasionally I'll change things in here
and do a reload for something else
it'll reload the components and it looks
like everything is fine and I forget
that I haven't moved those styles over
yet and then when I do actually have a
refresh my styles are all gone so just
be careful about that it doesn't happen
often but when it does happen it can be
really annoying if if you've done a lot
and you can't remember what you did all
right so this page is looking pretty
good about how we want it to still not
exactly sure that I like how this looks
but I'm gonna leave it alone for now
because I'm not sure what I want to do
with it so what I want to think about it
a little bit more I'm hoping that
something will come to me I'll just get
an idea one day and oh that's it that
would look great if that doesn't happen
then we'll have to come back and maybe I
can look for some inspiration online ask
some other people to take a look at it
but for now this page it does what we
want users can look for logos they can
sort filter by category they can get two
different versions of the logo and
that's what we want great let's go to
the home page and that'll probably be
the next thing that we work on I do want
to commit our changes before we move on
to a different page and after I commit
I'm going to take a look at the live
chat and see if there's any
so I don't want to I want to be very
aware of the time so that I make sure I
can I can talk to you all on the live
chat and answer your questions so I
actually have I just glanced at it very
quiet in the live chat today which is
fine i get i get to do get more work
done if the chat is quiet but it's kind
of odd because we do have a decent
number of people viewing but let's
commit so we'll do a git status let me
make this bigger I'm sure you all having
trouble seeing that okay so I just typed
in get status just to double-check what
what files have changed and logo CAS and
logos dot s CSS that's that's what I
expected to see so that's good now we're
gonna do get commit and then I'm gonna
add the AM flag and this da means we're
gonna add first so we're combining two
steps a get add with a git commit and
then the M means I'm gonna add the
commit message right here in in the
terminal along with the rest of the
command so let's say we Center
because it's another selecting defuse
category spacing yeah so generally you
do want to try to be as clear as you can
in your commit messages sometimes
depending on the project you're
contributing to or where you work at
there may be rules about what messages
you can use so for instance some in the
course I'm taking from Udacity they
actually have a guide a style guide for
get commits so there's a certain way
that I have to write all the commits
when I'm gonna when I'm doing a project
for that course so it's likely that
companies may have something similar as
well or particular projects all right so
the commit words have some additional
things going on for this site we have
this here where it says Husky this is
what's running everything to change so
it's running prettier using standard
jazz rules to format all of our code in
the same way which is nice so that
everyone that commits that all the code
gets formatted properly and you don't
have to worry about learning how I like
things formatted because it'll do it for
you
these are some tests and we've passed
all the tests and now it's been
committed so if you don't have all of
this stuff set up which you wouldn't if
it was you're just starting your own
project from scratch you would probably
just see this and that would let you
know that that it worked now we have one
final step since we're hosting this
repository on github we want to make
sure that we sync everything up with
github so in this case we have changes
on our local machine that aren't on
github yet so we want to push those
changes up so we're going to do git push
origin
master when the master we're pushing
everything the master branch there we go
so now we know it's up to github if
there would happen to be code on github
that we don't have yet on our local
machine instead we'd want to do get pull
and that will pull it down now I don't
I'm already up to date okay but it's a
good idea to do a get pull every time
you start you know when you start the
day do a get pull right off the bat and
then that way you'll your repository
will be up to date you know in case
there are some changes that other people
have made even if you're not working on
a team it's possible and I've done this
before that you may have made some
changes from a different computer and
just forgotten about it
so to get pools always a good idea okay
so let me check actually it looks like
there's not really any questions in the
live chat so I think I'm just gonna keep
coding I'm gonna say hi to everybody so
I see a lot of you said hi
so hey everyone I appreciate you
watching alright
we did have some pool requests that I
forgot to mention I actually I like to
give credit to those of you who are
submitting pool requests to the project
and let me think who had a pull request
Gavin Gavin submitted a pull request and
then we also had some clarifications and
discussion on some other pull requests
so that I was able to correct some
things in the project based on that
information so I appreciate that as well
Gavin's pool request was related to some
errors that that he was getting and it's
nice because perhaps some of you were
getting him I wasn't getting those
errors but just because I'm not getting
them on my machine in my setup doesn't
mean other people aren't I know there
have been some other errors that people
are getting so hopefully that not only
corrects Gavin's errors but maybe some
of you so if you had had some errors in
the past maybe you know you might want
to try pulling down
the latest code from the repo and scene
if they're fixed not all right so for
this page what I'd like to try to do is
bring in let's see I think it'd be nice
to have these centered vertically on the
page and also I'd like to bring in the
the real content and then see how it
lines up because I want all of these
cards to be the same height so right now
they are but it's only because they have
the exact same content I also would like
to change these to our our cards so we
had I think it was Rohit submitted a
pool request a while ago and he made a
card that basically you could put
anything in it any possible combination
that's common to material design cards
was possible to do within this one
component so it's very useful so I think
I'd like to change these to those
components Center it vertically and add
in the correct content
okay so let's do that first thing we
need to do is bring up the home page
yeah so here's our home page
mm sorry I just for some reason my music
just stopped it was how define I it was
really odd so it distracted me for a
second okay I got to the end of my
playlist that that makes sense
it didn't say it seemed like it just
stopped right in the middle of a song I
guess that's just how that song is I did
I saw a question come up in the live
chat that I do want to address so
breakpoint and I see breakpoint I think
you asked this somewhere else as well
like maybe in the github repo I think I
saw a message just come up earlier today
the question is about why electron was
added and being used in the project so
David had said I think it was for
running some of the tests and yeah so
basically from what I understand
so from what Gavin said I think
yesterday and the live chat is that he
was heating errors when he was trying to
run tests and the errors were saying
were related to electron saying that he
needed an electron so that's what
prompted him to add electron and it
fixed those areas for him I wasn't
having those errors but I thought I'd
pull it in anyway because as I said
there were other people that were having
errors that were related to testing and
things like that so I thought okay well
it's possible that this is going to fix
some of those problems so if it turns
out that it's not needed then I'm
definitely okay with removing it I just
want to make sure that everyone that's
trying to clone this repo and use it is
able to do so so it's kind of hard for
me to tell whether or not I need it
because like I said I wasn't getting any
of those errors on my machine so I can't
really I can't really remove it and test
it out because it's gonna work for me no
matter what so I don't know if anyone is
able to let's say replicate some of the
errors you know if you just remove
electron to see what happens on your
machine I'm not sure what Gavin was
running what his setup was so anyway
that's why electrons there right now
doesn't I don't know that it needs to be
there
okay let's let's get back to here let me
check the time okay we're still good we
got by like 20 minutes before I I want
to be done may not need a lot of time
for the question-and-answer since
there's just not a lot of questions yet
but I'll try to keep an eye on it
and if I see a lot of questions going in
I'll stop stop with the coding so let's
pull in so while while we have this
logos j/s file open we have a good
example of how to use that component
that generic card component so let's do
that first
we'll have them side by side and I'm
gonna close close that on the side so
that we have a bit more space so our
card let's show you I'll show you where
this card is where do we use that oh I
know here was at the top okay so we have
our card here right it's that word now
it ends here okay oops okay so this
whole section here is our card I'm just
going to copy that and paste it here for
now just so that we can see it so what
we need we don't need everything for for
this card so for instance we won't need
our image so we can take that out the
really cool thing about this generic
card is that everything is just
controlled by the props that we pass in
so if we don't pass them in we just
don't get that part so I've removed the
image source and now I don't have the
image part of the card really it's
really cool so we don't have to add a
lot it it just simplified the
alternative was if there was a bit more
to add in and make sure that you
included in your project let's say like
up here so for instance like we had to
import card card title card text now we
won't have to do that that's all taken
care of in the generic card component so
just simplifies things a bit so we won't
need these buttons
let's see look in fact we won't need the
actions prop at all actually let me
double check let me double check the
current version before I start removing
everything
that's so this is the current version
and okay great yeah we don't have any
items there so we can remove those
actions oops and get it all so removing
the actions so now we can actually
remove this class as well so we're doing
it in it so what we'll need
let's get check out our generic card
component text
I guess we needed Cyril
we're gonna have to do a little bit
extra styling so just the default for
cards is that things are left aligned
obviously you know it's not going to be
like that
so I suppose title and I don't really
want to go with the subtitle for this
text so this would be the normal body
text so we'll definitely need a title
subtitle these this area with the icons
is going to be a little bit challenging
because we don't have that built into
our generic card but I'm not really sure
when I keep the phone icons or not let
me know what you all think I mean people
are used to the icons but really I don't
know I don't know that they serve that
much of a purpose when I originally put
them in I just I thought that it needed
something that this was just way too
plain and it would be better if there
was something and it was also nice to
have some continuity here so that like
my thought was that at a glance people
would know what this is but really like
I've stared at this thing for hours when
I was building it and I still don't know
at a glance what each of these are this
is probably you know maybe the only one
that's the most straightforward because
if you knew that that was the symbol for
PowerPoint I suppose you could figure
out that's PowerPoint but the rest of it
I don't know so maybe I'll leave them
out for now until I decide for sure
whether or not I want to do do them and
then if I do want to I'll figure out how
to how to make that work with our
generic card component
but for now let's try to put in
to see where how we have the okay so car
title is definitely a prop car title and
oops put in for the first one is brand
manual so let's just put that in we also
need to include this generic card
what I'm trying to look for now is did
we have a prop for text title so time I
think we didn't so I think what we ended
up with was just whatever text that
would put in here so I'd get rid of this
and then add in the text so
oops need ads in their generic card okay
so I thank whatever is in here ends up
being the sexy because we have children
under card text so let's see if that
works okay great
so that did work so I can safely get get
rid of I think all these cards and let's
stick with this for now and let's bump
this up
oh well that'll I'm not worried about
how that looks it'll get Auto formatted
soon so we can get rid of all of these
cards and since they're all the same we
can highlight them and I can just paste
in this and I pasted this twice so let's
get rid of that so if you like that
little trick its multiple cursors so if
we're depending on what editor you use
it'll probably have multiple cursors
with atom you press command D on a Mac
or I think it's control D on Windows and
I'm getting a call I think it's a spam
call on my cell phone so I've been
getting calls from somebody claiming to
be the IRS and saying that I messed up
on my taxes I haven't answered it I've
just gotten their messages I'm really
tempted to answer it and just play along
for a while just for fun but I just
haven't I've been too busy for that okay
cool so here's all our cards using the
generic card component definitely think
that's too much space in between there
so we'll work on that but for now let's
go ahead and get to learn okay let's put
in the correct content for each of these
since I have it up here may as well do
it
whose
I was trying to copy and paste but it's
actually it's difficult because each one
of the cards are clickable so it keeps
navigating away so I may have to type
this up logos and posters it might not
be a great idea cuz this will be pretty
boring
all right how about let's not add all
that in because that's probably boring
for your shoot I wanted one that I
wanted one that was bigger than the
others just to try I guess if I Shrunk
it enough I might there we go that's all
I really wanted was I just wanted one to
be a bit taller okay so I don't think I
have time to do both of these but I want
to make sure that these cards are always
the same height and then I also want to
align these vertically so I'm wondering
we've already done vertical alignment
like last week I think so let's try to
make these all the same height I know
that there's a way that I've used before
with Flex box that makes this easy to do
but it depends on the structure of the
div so I know with materialise it didn't
work because of the div structure it may
work here though yeah yes I think it
will work okay cool and I think that I
on the current site yes I did all right
all right so let me pull this over just
to show you how I've done this so I've
added some flex box display flex flex
I thought I did it with these ones let
me double check
yeah I think I did okay so let me move
this off to the side and we'll try to
apply some of those same things here and
I think the structure is close enough
that yeah I think it's close enough that
it should work what was that it looks
like guys use bootstrap for this I
I forgot that I use bootstrap actually
for it
it appears that I somehow use both the
bootstrap and materialized for this
project I don't know what I was thinking
maybe I don't I don't really know it was
too long ago I can't remember zama says
that's not bootstrap yeah
no some of it the the thing that made me
think it was bootstrap is because I have
this class Jumbotron and I have this
column MD for which I thought was how
bootstrap did their column so that's
definitely not materialized columns are
are like this so the rest of it the
styles are more like you know what the
user sees are materialized and so I've
liked this card huh verbal that's from
materialized so I vaguely remember
switching like halfway through so I
think I started with bootstrap and then
I went to materialise but I may have
just left in some of the bootstrap
classes and maybe copied some of the
code so like maybe I just left a bit of
bootstrap CSS in there I sincerely hope
that I did not actually load all the
bootstrap and all the materialized on
this project I don't I'm not even gonna
check to see if I did you say I'm gonna
be I'll be mad at myself if I did that
so if I didn't already say this this is
this project was quite a while ago that
I originally did this so I'm much more
knowledgeable now
Zama says in your Styles it seems it's
coming from Markham Tubman dot CSS yeah
that's I ended up putting I think
everything in the Markham tabbed up men
dot CSS so it's it's entirely possible
that there's a mixture of different
frameworks and custom stuff all in there
like I said I I'm pretty sure I did
start with bootstrap but then I didn't
finish I went to materialise so I'm not
sure if I just left the classes and
there's nothing going on with them or
what what I did exactly
but in any case I think it's close
enough that we can try to could try to
do the same thing so let's go I think we
had to display flex on the row was that
yeah display flex on the row and then
flex Rab okay so my strategy for this is
I'm just gonna copy over everything
exactly how it was and then I'm gonna
try to get rid of stuff to see if I
actually need all of this or not so for
this with whoops display flex okay so so
far not really anything no we did have
some stuff happening right we had so you
notice some change not really a change
to the better and then here on our card
okay let's do
and this is not
we're not really given a class here
let's see if I can try to do it like
that yeah whoops I just wanted to see if
I could select all of these we'll need
to add a class I suppose so we need just
flex okay not oh this at this point this
is actually what we want right they're
all the same height and width at least
per row so that's what we want
I mean it's messed things up in here but
we can that can be the next step so this
is good for now let's go likes X
direction hmm
okay
it's
actually wow that that works it works
and yeah it needs a little bit of
adjustment here but alright that that
achieves what we want so now I'm gonna
very carefully move move this over so I
can see it and we're gonna add those
styles here so I'll probably do some
inline styles and then do I have I'm not
sure that I have a a sass file already
for home no I don't so we may have to
make that but I think I'm gonna run out
of time before I make that yeah so let's
let's at least get some of it going in
line here just to make sure that it
works and then for this row we had flex
or display flex and I believe we also
had flex wrap so since the CSS inside
the style is an array or I'm sorry an
object with key value pairs we put a
comma between each CSS declaration so
flex
fix rap
okay now on this column in accuser
I'm gonna remove this row because that
was causing some of the spacing issues
that we saw when it went down to one
column should I remove that row and here
now we only have to worry about flex on
that rows as well so on this diff see
this is where I I definitely want to
make time I'm not gonna have time so
basically just to let you know what's
gonna happen so we've already done it in
dev tools we've know that it works what
needs to happen next and what will
happen is those Styles just need to be
applied to each column and then to each
card and the way I'm going to do that is
I'm going to create another SAS file
just like we did with logos so it'll be
home dot s CSS and then I'll put those
styles that are gonna apply to each one
of these columns and each one of these
cards in there and then we'll import it
at the top like we did in logos so we'll
grab stock import our Styles literally
home dot dot CSS and then everything we
need will get applied so that's pretty
straightforward I'll probably finish
that up before I leave today and I'll
push that to the repo in case you all
want to check it out once it's finished
okay cool that's not bad actually god I
wasn't sure that we'd even get that for
but I'd like to take the rest of the
time let's in the next four minutes to
answer any questions that you might have
if you were just here for the code you
don't want to stick around for the next
five minutes of questions I really
appreciate you joining in and I'll be
back next week otherwise put your
question in now if I don't get you a
question because I have to go to my
performance review please send it to me
on Twitter or any social media or as a
comment
and I'll try to get to it as soon as I
can I do know that I'm a bit backed up
on getting to some of the YouTube
comments I know that I have not forgot
you I will try to catch up when I can
just been been a bit busy lately I'm
sure you all know that I go sometimes
you just have a lot going on okay
okay so we have we still had some
discussion about electron being in use
so if certainly if we had I don't think
we have very much yet in in the repo
actually this might not be a bad idea to
bring up as an issue so that we can have
a record of the discussion of it because
we have had some stuff in the live chat
but that's not really persistent enough
so that people can can keep joining in
so if I remember later after my meeting
maybe I'll make an issue about it just
to discuss whether or not we need
electron or what all are our
alternatives should be if one of you
want to make the issue before then feel
free we can continue the discussion
about it there and then anyone can join
in let's see
let's see
skillful mess says has he ever ran this
yet are you talking I I'm assuming
you're talking about this project but
I'm not sure I mean in terms of have I
ever ran it I it's I mean it's running
locally I haven't put it on a server yet
but I have every reason to believe that
it would it would work on a server as
well
okay Rohan just had a really good point
I was I was wondering about this myself
in regard to electron being used said
probably it's one of the dependent one
of the dependencies required but for
some reason isn't declared if it's not
declared it won't be downloaded as a sub
dependency so yeah I am I thought I
thought that I'm not sure how likely
that is the but I think it's a good
point okay
Rowen also says the other possibility is
that it does use headless chrome to run
tests if you don't have chrome or
disabled headless it tries electron and
then there's the optional undeclared
dependency that that makes a lot of
sense if I if I had to guess which one
is the right answer to our problem here
that's what I would guess I'm not sure I
don't think I asked Aven what browser
he was trying I mean I would assume he
would have Chrome but I never asked so
okay rhoann says no icons and left the
line looks nice
okay cool it does look a bit bare in
terms of there's just not a lot I mean
this is an odd-shaped screen let's make
it more reasonable okay this is a more
reasonable sized screen for people on
campus at least so alright yeah it
doesn't look that bad like this yeah
well I'm not gonna worry about it until
we get the actual content in there no no
use you know trying to see your nitpick
about the look I guess until we get the
real content in okay David said the page
looks a bit bare without some kind of
icon there's a lot of white space
Rowlands is vertically centering would
make it look better
yeah let's check it out I David I I do
agree it does look bare I'm just I'm
thinking about we'll see yeah I'm
thinking about adding these icons back
in but yeah I really do want to see what
it looks like with the real content in
there and vertically centered and then
then I think I can decide about the the
logos or the icons I mean
breakpoint asks what command with these
users doing that cause the airs actually
sorry everyone I'm not gonna get to
address all the questions I just looked
up and it is 2:30 so I need to go see my
boss now for a performance review
so hopefully I've done a good job this
year and it'll be a nice performance
review and otherwise it's Friday right
it's just the weekend so I won't see you
all until Monday so have a great weekend
thank you so much for watching and I'll
see you later